cleaning your carpet is a great way to
start fresh for this new year so let's
welcome back zero red the sponsors of
this next segment tino show us the way
as we're out with the old in with the
new right that's right
so what have we accumulated in our
carpets over the years that we need to
get rid of this year you know we've
accumulated a lot of nasty stuff yeah i
can imagine a lot of a lot of dirt a lot
of nasty things but zero rise we clean
with this revolutionary patented process
that eliminates the need for soaps and
harsh chemicals and what that means for
you as a homeowner or a business owner
is your carpets and your flooring is
going to be like factory new there's not
going to be any crunchy residue left
behind your toes will love how the
carpet feels and i can just smell it oh
yeah i can just imagine the smell of
clean carpet i love that so how does it
work i know we have a the hardware here
to show everybody so we we use a truck
mounted system which is typical in the
industry but we have industry-leading
equipment imagine a 300 horsepower
vacuum our vacuum is powered actually by
the truck's engine
so it's incredibly powerful it removes
up to 200 percent more soil and
contaminants than our leading
competitors out there wow and i know
during this time where everyone's
worried about germs that is very
important for everyone so let's see how
it works let's put it to the test
so what are we cleaning up what's what's
in the carpet right now so this is a
this is just a typical soiled carpet you
find at your home
and with our powered water technology
there's no soaps there's no surfactants
you can see right away the cleaning
results that come from it this is just
water there's no no harsh chemicals
involved
and my favorite part rocky is it dries
extremely fast that is so important
that's so important yeah and look at
that
it's just coming right up it's a
nine-day difference
and now just besides the you know the
dirt and the grime this is also good for
your health and clean air right it does
there's a there's actually a study that
was done out there
where they study the air quality after
carpet cleaning okay and they found that
up to 52 percent of the dust
contaminants on the air can be removed
just by cleaning carpets and it's
because the carpet's the largest air
filter in your home or your facility and
so if it's dirty it's not doing its job
of
filtering out those contaminants for you
wow so how much space do you guys cover
you come in and you do the whole house
how does it work uh we could do yeah all
your carpets we clean tile and grout we
can clean up wood floors stone uh we
even clean air ducts okay okay okay so
special offers for the new year what are
we talking so right now we're throwing
out a great special you can get your
carpets cleaned at your home for as low
as 35 dollars per room
and if you clean three rooms we're gonna
throw in a free hallway
um just as a gift for this new year for
you oh my god music to our ears and
congratulations to you guys on best of
las vegas again what does that honor
mean for you and the company it's
incredible it just shows you know where
we have a team and we focus on our
customer experience we want to make sure
that you feel comfortable when we come
into your home especially you know given
these days it's it's crazy inviting
service people into your home or
business
but know that we're going to come in
we're going to treat you right and make
you feel like you're part of the family
that's awesome and you guys have won
this three years in a row that's correct
so you're doing something right i think
they know what they're doing so this is
awesome thank you so much you guys and
you have to take advantage of this a
special offer for the year give zero res
a call at
minimum 702-840-333-3333 of course that
is amazing offer thank you guys thank
you